hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the final one now this is
supposedly an indie horror game that
features terrifying creepy dolls in some
sort of fashion which is always an
a-plus in my book and I'm eager to see
what sort of pseudo mannequin desk thing
is gonna be in this one okay from what
you told you think there are someone
staring dis trouble up right yeah it's
just like I told you any competitive
business we would use any metal in all
means to crush only rules no matter how
much we got dirty I agree what did you
think spreading rumors about how that
goes it's a bit irrational no oh I think
you silly do however it does cause the
delay of the construction of my DS the
web is runway and it affects a lot of my
plan I understood that's the reason I
want you to investigate and self proof
because for my own opinion I don't think
those kind of rumors will really affect
my
do not worry maybe if they're a hire you
employee to do that oh yeah trust me I
will do my best in the investigation
what I think is a plan are your reforms
I think of that too I'll leave it to you
today I gave my word that I wanted to
fight you Oh believe in you just don't
get haunted by the ghost it sure ha ha
ha ha what are the odds that that could
happen in little Dhaka what's happening
ah don't you see him okay alright so
supposedly this businessman hired this
investigator to see if it's haunted with
ghosts but the business or the
investigator thinks that maybe it was
just business rivals trying to do stuff
but why would he not be able to know
where his employees are how would he not
know if their murderer or not did they
just run away without telling anybody
did no one go here why am I here why mo
okay here we go then okay oh this looks
good oh yeah I've seen great many
museums that are haunted in my day and
this ranks up at the top oh hi hello
oh god hi hello oh I don't like you
already oh I can already tell how much I
hate you oh I'm not gonna have fun here
alrighty then let's see what's going on
in this horrible museum like what kind
of business is this this is the worst
museum ever why would you have anybody
working here wait am i working here
oh it's fine isn't it okay find a way to
operate the elevator I'm in it to win it
hang on one second I got crank up the
volume so I can hear myself and
everything that's gonna kill me alright
hi hello sorry to disturb you go back to
sleep let me look at my objective before
I find out what's gonna kill me oh hi
Oh many dolls oh you're probably just as
lethal I thought something was behind
okay there's a lot of you why are there
a lot of you oh hi yeah alright enough
the chorus of babies could stop
screaming for one second maybe I could
get some concentration going on here oh
what's in here
oh that looks highly technical and
advanced why is it here hello oh I can
save oh that's awfully convenient
okay well that shut by me didn't it ah
piss
oh hello hi alrighty then EBU baby boot
the cacophony of screaming toddlers has
not subsided hi hello yeah that's
probably a good idea don't know why that
required a cutscene but okay we save one
more dude daddy time let me guess all
the mannequins are gone now and I'm not
gonna hello oh you're still there
oh you're delightful maybe oh hey oh I
didn't notice the painting the really
disconcerting painting why would anybody
make a painting of dolls okay you're
still there let's play hey that's what
this video is okay glad you know the
subject matter oh you're lovely oh
you're so lovely yeah yeah
yeah I'm so chance right you then
anything else over okay never mind then
that plant was blocking my way can so go
to the elevator now goodbye every okay
hello my name is markiplier you want to
be part of this let's play - oh god hi
okay
who's there anybody okay all right off
we go then I think I'm okay now I can
finish off this investigation in peace
oh hi uh I think I found the missing
employees he might not be dead that is
an option what do I get a do I get a gun
oh hell yeah okay I don't know why my
first instinct was to try to shoot that
guy but that probably wasn't a good
thing so if he had a gun why didn't that
work for him well as a cinematic piece
of masterpiece right there
okey-dokey then I'll save ya sure okay
who wants to come get some I've got a
heaping helping load of bullets
jeez stop stop stop stop I just had the
craziest flashback to cry of fear like I
legitimately had the craziest flashback
to like four years ago when I was
playing cry of fear because I remember
the cacophony of screaming children in a
lot of games but for some reason that
really reminded me of cry of fear and
this wait a minute I bet if I reload
this gun it's gonna lose the bullets
that are in it so I'm gonna keep that
and then hopefully thank you god what a
[ __ ] that is so cry of fear oh also how
but whoa
there's so cry of fear oh hello okay
goodbye
but hello all right um
yeah first aid yes please thank you I
don't know how to use the first
No
how about you don't do that you crazy
crazy doll mm I bet I didn't need to
unload my entire clip from the gun but
felt like it was necessary in the moment
find the power rooms key okay can do
this staircase doesn't make a lot of
sense but okay whatever don't throw
rocks at me how'd you older hurling
bastard [ __ ] em that is 100% so cry fear
and I love that man it's been so long
since I played that game I always meant
to go back and finish it the super extra
way don't even think about it
maybe you're the peaceful one maybe
you're not actually gonna know all right
all right
reloading okay got you all right I can
reload I can waste one bullet better
than being caught with my pants down
when screamers are sprinting down my
face okay all right then who is that a
key is that the key I need is that an
employee is he deed ow
my grundle a [ __ ] god dammit my
stupid FPS instincts yeah in the cry
fear you had to you had to conserve your
ammo a lot you had to make sure that you
didn't reload because obviously if
you're in a horror situation you
wouldn't have time to exchange the
bullets from one clip to another hi how
you doing
okay this is cool by the way I like this
a lot I don't like that can I get out
can I just dive headfirst through the
window and get out that'd be really nice
okay elevators working now that's
awfully convenient for me and everybody
around here well I have enough bullets
who's doing that whoo hi hello
who else is here helping me who's a help
II help Burton someone in here maybe no
won't open
okay then I'll be on my way Oh mr.
Wickham all right
why are you here ah I have been
kidnapped for three days but I just
talked to you on a phone
that wasn't me I'm not gonna make it but
I've gathered all the evidence it's in
the office room on the first before you
should go there and you know
oh okay so wit him mr. Winn hung oh well
he survived three days and then he died
just in time too I have to go to the
office room yeah kind of kind of seems
like that he died just in time to give
me a plot device
well sorry mr. Wilhelm do you have any
ammo that I could use you still seem to
be breathing I don't think you're dead
yet but you know I'm not gonna help you
I'm just gonna walk away and imagine all
the other things I can do in my life
while I'm not dead okay goodbye
ding-dong Bing bong okay I guess I gotta
go to the office and discover the the
truth whatever the truth may be whatever
the truth may hold also sorry like if
I'm a little lispy and spitty today it's
because yesterday we did a challenge
where that involved warheads and we
melted off the entirety of our mouths so
it's it's a it's a little little
uncomfortable to talk and it just seems
like I'm slightly inebriated but I try I
trust me I've done I can't drink
okay
delayed reaction door I never expected
the delayed reaction door oh man oh okay
all right sorry physics-based delayed
reaction door all right i'ma go we got
miss unlimited oh I did no wait I say
that was it Oh God
I don't want to go down there okay hello
all right which one of these doors is
gonna hit me missed me and now you're
did find the key to open the office room
okay so that's the office I've got some
extra ammo and I'm doing pretty good
unable to kill these things it's been a
while since I played a [ __ ] game that
actually involved combat what the [ __ ]
because usually not always but usually
combat removes a little bit of the scare
to it because you're you're you're less
you know you're less threatened when
you're just you and yourself with a gun
instead of just Union yourself with [ __ ]
in your pants you know it's easily like
a trade-off but in this one it seems to
be working pretty well because the
original cry fear was all about weapons
and killing the things but it was so
interesting in the diverse environments
that you were in that it created this
unique world that was just fun to go
through and terrifying at the same time
and always with the new monsters coming
around every corner it really made a
diverse okay the truth the truth if
you're listening to this perhaps I that
wasn't him up there either the truth
about a mystery of this museum
in the past this place wasn't lessening
that nose after this unit were affected
by we walked noble afternoon this place
was burned and I found out it was caused
by the demolitions
yeah washes the most musky the wait time
as a sacrifice to the Satan they believe
this ain't a lot of people at the same
time at the same place in a most
torturous new again incredible it bleeds
the horse to be successful
and nothing can stop it there would be
more powerful than any would be now
because you know what I mean it is
regretful to hear that everyone MacEwan
the fire burned everything into ashes
and years and years of this dog ISM has
been constructed for displays why what
the heck II indeed indeed you you wonder
what's happening with the pines being no
dog
we decided because the second life that
he was shortened his right was like a
dream for 15 years
unfortunately he found it was not as
good as we should be rather he found
that Alysha was like a breed someone was
gone from the ratio that Aaron egged him
so much but finally who was the
fundament is it me is it me me hey
hahaha
that doesn't make any sense oh hey ow my
face why you do that I knew he wasn't
dead Oh
save save game save game okay - big
mistake from the 15 years ago and we
could make leashes and everything would
be complete how about we don't all
suffering will be gone
no thank you oh sorry miss Rogerson
did I wake you up don't you know that I
have been looking for you for a long
long time no oh I didn't know last I
found you
okay I didn't expect that you become a
detective it looks like you want to know
about your past
yes I will grant you wish
to someone to you to Eddie that someone
is Satan who respect to me
okay I really like it so ass the Satan's
say that your mom was so delicious
ah that's a weird thing to say in
multiple ways
now it's time to see you mother Oh
lovely
family reunions are always good ha ha ha
oh hi oh my god okay well this was
unaccustomed
is awesome bad hey hey stop it hey stop
it stop it you're super freaky and I
heart there we go
I found your weakness it's your your
conspicuously open heart and stabbing
mechanisms won't work because I'm all
the way back here
I could have guns inhale oh boy incoming
Wow hold my face now all my face oh I
killed Satan I killed him I killed him
dead he's dead now I am the winner of
hell I guess I get that now that's nice
I suppose oh [ __ ] ah [ __ ]
you thought they would have learned
their lesson the first time when they
built the Museum of horrifying dolls on
top of the flaming wreckage of an
abandoned orphanage filled with dead
children because someone probably would
have known about it also how did she
survive how did she escape cheap tuck
and roll as a toddler out the window but
somehow didn't learn those skills now
guys a toddler Oh God demonic fire you
bust out of the window roll a few feet
hit your head lose your memory then
become a detective and lose all those
survival skills except when you get a
gun and then shoot Satan in the heart
but either way that was the final one
and the name makes sense now I totally
get it there were some hiccups in this
but it's outweighed by the fact that I
actually really enjoyed the gameplay
obviously the narration wasn't perfect
because they didn't speak English as
their first language
but this was good it had good flow to it
and I actually liked the combat I
haven't said that about a horror game in
a long time and I think it's because
it's reminiscent of cry fear there were
a diverse number of enemies so how short
the game was there were like three
different enemy types for if you include
the first doll that came after you but
it's just really interesting to see how
combat can work if you have a diverse
enough environment and enemy type that
keeps things interesting
but either way I'll leave it at that let
me know what you guys thought of it down
in the comments below I'm going to rest
my tongue I don't know how I'm gonna do
that and that just sounds weird when I
say it out loud but I'm gonna do just
that but thank you everybody so much for
watching and
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye